It's that time of year when parents and other caregivers race to find the hottest toys and stock up on classic favorites. From poppets to Pokemon, from squishmallows to Legos. Toys might seem frivolous, but to psychologists, they're a subject for serious study. Researchers have long known that children learn best through play. Play is how kids stretch their brains and develop crucial cognitive, social, and other skills. toys are a fundamental part of playtime. But what makes something a good toy? Indeed, what makes something a toy at all?
每到这个时节，家长和其他看护人都会争相寻找最热门的玩具，并囤积经典的畅销款。从按压泡泡玩具到宝可梦，从毛绒公仔到乐高，玩具看起来似乎微不足道，但对心理学家而言，它们是一个严肃的研究课题。研究人员早就知道，儿童在玩耍中学习效果最好。玩耍是孩子们拓展思维、发展关键认知、社交及其他技能的方式。玩具是玩耍的基本组成部分。但什么才算是一个好玩具？事实上，到底什么才算是玩具？
Why do some toys stand the test of time, while others are just a one-season wonder? What's the difference between fun and educational toys? Why do we assign gender appropriateness to some toys and not to others? How do kids' toy preferences change as they age, and how has technology change what toys are and the way kids play with toys. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology,
为什么有些玩具经得起时间的考验，而有些却只是昙花一现？有趣玩具和益智玩具之间有什么区别？为什么我们给某些玩具贴上性别标签，而对其他玩具则不然？随着年龄增长，孩子们的玩具偏好如何改变？科技又是如何改变玩具的定义以及孩子们玩玩具的方式的？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，
the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Our first is Dr. Barry Kudrowitz, an associate professor and director of product design at the University of Minnesota Twin Cities,
这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天我们邀请到了两位嘉宾。第一位是巴里·库德罗维茨博士，他是明尼苏达大学双城分校的产品设计副教授兼主任，
where he teaches classes in toy product design. Dr. Kudrowitz has a PhD in mechanical engineering from the Massachusetts Institute of Technology, where he studied creativity, humor, and idea generation, and he has studied how play can fuel creativity and innovation. In addition to his academic career, he's also a toy designer. Highlights of his work include the Katsup Krapper, an anthropomorphic roller skating ketchup bottle that he designed as a grad student, and the Nerf Adam Blaster, a Nerf toy sold by Hasbro more than five years.
他在那里教授玩具产品设计课程。库德罗维茨博士拥有麻省理工学院机械工程博士学位，研究方向包括创造力、幽默感和创意生成，他还研究过玩耍如何激发创造力和创新。除了学术生涯外，他也是一名玩具设计师。他的代表作包括他在研究生时期设计的拟人化溜冰番茄酱瓶“Katsup Krapper”，以及孩之宝销售超过五年的“Nerf Adam Blaster”发射器。
Our second guest is Dr. Doris Bergen, a distinguished professor emerita of educational psychology at Miami University in Oxford, Ohio. Dr. Bergen began her career as a pre-kindergarten and elementary school teacher. And over her long academic career, she has explored the many ways that play is crucial to children's development. She has studied play and humor in early and middle childhood, the effects of technology enhanced toys, and cross-cultural considerations in play among many other topics. Dr. Bergen has authored or edited more than a dozen books, including her most recent, the Handbook of Developmentally Appropriate Toys, which was published in March 2021. Thank you both for joining us today.
我们的第二位嘉宾是多丽丝·伯根博士，她是俄亥俄州牛津市迈阿密大学教育心理学的杰出荣誉教授。伯根博士的职业生涯始于学前班和小学教师。在她漫长的学术生涯中，她探索了玩耍对儿童发展的诸多关键作用。她研究过幼儿和童年中期的玩耍与幽默、科技增强型玩具的影响，以及玩耍中的跨文化考量等诸多课题。伯根博士撰写或编辑了十几本书，包括她于2021年3月出版的最新著作《适龄玩具手册》。感谢两位今天来到我们的节目。
Thanks for having me. God be here. All right. So let's start with a broad question, which we usually do. What is the purpose of toys and what makes something a good toy or make something a toy at all? For example, can a stick or a rock be a toy? Actually, toys have existed for a long, long time. You can even find them in early sites.
谢谢邀请。很高兴能来。好的。那么，让我们从一个通常会问的宏大问题开始。玩具的目的是什么？什么才算是一个好玩具，或者说到底什么才算是玩具？例如，一根棍子或一块石头能成为玩具吗？事实上，玩具已经存在了很长很长的时间。你甚至可以在早期的遗址中发现它们。
And so some of the typical toys that children still play with today, like dolls and wheel toys, things that sort, have been around for a long time. But I would say that the purpose of toys, in my view, is to enhance children's play, because children will play, even if there aren't any toys. They'll find sticks or they'll find rocks or they'll find other things to use in their pretend play and in their gameplay. But toys are a means of enhancing the play and making it more creative and often more elaborative.
因此，一些孩子们今天仍在玩的典型玩具，比如玩偶和带轮子的玩具，这类东西已经存在很久了。但我认为，玩具的目的在于增强儿童的玩耍体验，因为即使没有玩具，孩子们也会玩耍。他们会找棍子、石头或其他东西来用于假装游戏和游戏活动。但玩具是一种增强玩耍、使其更具创造性且往往更丰富多彩的手段。
Yeah, I agree. Toys are a tool for play. And, you know, there's a difference between a toy and a toy product. There are certain toys that are designed by people to be intended to be used for play. And then there's things that are not designed, you know, intended to be used for play that children still play with, like cardboard boxes and spoons and rakes and stuff, right? There's still toys, but maybe they're not toy products. And many toy products are designed by people who have ideas about what they think is good for children to play with.
是的，我同意。玩具是玩耍的工具。而且，你知道，玩具和玩具产品之间是有区别的。有些玩具是人们专门设计出来用于玩耍的。而有些东西并非为了玩耍而设计，但孩子们依然会玩，比如纸箱、勺子、耙子之类的东西，对吧？它们仍然是玩具，但可能不是“玩具产品”。许多玩具产品是由那些对“什么适合孩子玩”有自己想法的人设计的。
Maybe they think they'll learn particular things from them. They have different expectations about the toys. And I would say a really good toy is one that doesn't do everything itself, but has the child do it. Unfortunately, I think some toys designed do too much, and there isn't really even room for children to do very much with them. And so those toys typically don't have very lasting value. Maybe kids will play with them for a while, learn what they do,
也许他们认为孩子能从中学习到特定的东西。他们对玩具抱有不同的期望。而我会说，一个真正的好玩具，不是那种自己能做所有事情的玩具，而是能让孩子参与其中的玩具。遗憾的是，我认为有些玩具设计得太“全能”了，孩子几乎没有发挥的空间。因此，这些玩具通常没有持久的价值。也许孩子们会玩上一阵子，了解它们的功能，
and then they'll probably turn them into something else and use them in a different way or maybe discard them altogether. And are those things that you think about, Dr. Kudrowitz, when you're designing toys or teaching people how to design toys? I mean, I'm thinking about them, but not necessarily the students. And even when we do playtesting, it's not necessarily even the children that we playtest are thinking about those things. Oftentimes, it's what is trendy or popular that they might gravitate to. but I also think that what makes the toy a good toy is that it can be used in a variety of different contexts and it doesn't die. You know, you can use it for generations, for example, or in multiple different ways of playing.
然后他们可能会把它们变成别的东西，以不同的方式使用，或者干脆丢弃。库德罗维茨博士，当您在设计玩具或教别人如何设计玩具时，会考虑这些吗？我的意思是，我在考虑这些，但学生们不一定。即使我们在进行游戏测试时，我们测试的孩子也不一定在考虑这些。通常，他们会被潮流或热门的东西所吸引。但我同样认为，一个好玩具的特质在于它可以在多种不同的情境下使用，而且不会“过时”。你知道，它可以被几代人使用，或者以多种不同的方式玩耍。
You know, like the cardboard box is a great example. We actually have a box in our dining room right now from a couch, but it's been played with by the children for months now and we left this giant box in the dining room. And they play with that more than, you know, all the toys we've got in so far. It's a fort. It's a rocket ship. They're drawing all over the walls. They're cutting out holes. And that was free.
你知道，纸箱就是一个很好的例子。我们餐厅里现在就有一个装沙发的箱子，但孩子们已经玩了好几个月了，我们把这个巨大的箱子留在餐厅里。他们玩这个箱子的次数比我们买的所有玩具都要多。它是一个堡垒，是一艘火箭飞船。他们在墙上乱涂乱画，挖出洞来。而且那是免费的。
And it's compostable. And I think it's fantastic. There are sort of different kinds of play, you know, of course, and different kind of toys facilitate different kinds. If you're thinking of just kind of exploratory play or, manipulative play, that's one kind of toy that'll work for that. If you're looking at pretend play, there's a whole range of other kinds of toys that are really facilitative of pretense. And then, of course, there's game play of all different kinds and very different kinds of toys for that. And there's certainly some overlap among those.
而且它还可以堆肥。我觉得这太棒了。当然，玩耍有不同的种类，不同的玩具促进不同类型的玩耍。如果你考虑的是探索性游戏或操作性游戏，那会有相应的玩具。如果你关注的是假装游戏，还有一系列其他类型的玩具能很好地促进这种想象。当然，还有各种各样的游戏活动，也有非常不同的玩具。这些类别之间肯定会有一些重叠。
But the type of play that the child is going to do, if it's active play, quiet play, or of various sorts will usually need, or at least there'll be an expectation that different kinds of toys will meet the needs for different kinds of play. So a lot of parents think that toys come in basically two categories. And Dr. Bergen, you just described several categories, not just two, but for parents, they think they're educational toys, like those that are designed to teach science or math or reading, and then there are toys that are for fun, which covers pretty much everything else. Is that a valid distinction? And is there a difference between a fun toy and an educational toy?
但孩子将要进行的玩耍类型，无论是主动玩耍、安静玩耍还是其他各种形式，通常都需要，或者至少人们会期望不同的玩具能满足不同玩耍的需求。所以很多家长认为玩具基本上分为两类。伯根博士，您刚才描述了几个类别，不只是两类，但家长们认为有益智玩具，比如那些旨在教授科学、数学或阅读的玩具，还有就是为了好玩的玩具，这几乎涵盖了其他所有东西。这种区分有效吗？好玩的玩具和益智玩具之间有区别吗？
Should there be? I mean, going back to the very first thing we talked about, the primary purpose of a toy is play. And if the primary purpose is to teach something, it may not be a very good toy. But, you know, that being said, play is how we learn. That's how we've learned skills growing up, as we learned developmental skills, cognitive skills, physical skills.
应该有区别吗？我的意思是，回到我们谈论的第一点，玩具的主要目的是玩耍。如果主要目的是为了教学，那它可能不是一个好玩具。但是，话虽如此，玩耍是我们学习的方式。这就是我们在成长过程中学习技能的方式，我们学习发展技能、认知技能、身体技能。
And so you could also argue that no matter what kind of play, if you're engaging in play, you could argue that you're learning something. And so it's a little bit hard to separate those two, but I don't necessarily like the idea of a toy being primarily designed to be teaching you something. I would agree. I think that's maybe more of a marketing distinction than it is a toy distinction, because I think children learn from every type of play and from every type of toy. They may not be learning a specific thing like letters or whatever the toy maker thought they would do. But they also learn many other
所以你也可以说，无论进行哪种玩耍，只要你参与其中，就可以说你在学习。因此，要把这两者分开有点困难，但我并不一定喜欢那种主要为了教学而设计的玩具。我同意。我认为这更多是一种营销上的区分，而不是玩具本身的区分，因为我认为孩子们从每一种玩耍和每一种玩具中都能学到东西。他们可能学到的不是字母之类的特定知识，也不是玩具制造商所预想的内容。但他们也学到了许多其他
social and physical and intellectual skills from just about any toy. So I think the distinction educational toys is primarily a distinction for parents and for teachers and people who think that, oh, if it says educational, it's going to have a greater educational factor. The other way that educational toy could be seen is if there's a specific kind of teaching that the adult wants a child to have. And unfortunately, sometimes those kind of toys that are very specifically designed to teach a certain thing are either not used very often by the child or the child transforms them in some way into pretend or something else. And they don't exactly use them in the same. same way that the person who designed them thought they would use them.
社交、身体和智力技能，几乎从任何玩具中都能学到。所以我认为“益智玩具”这个区分主要是为了家长、老师以及那些认为“哦，如果上面写着益智，它就会有更大的教育价值”的人而设的。另一种看待益智玩具的方式是，如果成年人希望孩子掌握某种特定的教学内容。遗憾的是，有时那些专门设计用来教授特定知识的玩具，要么孩子不怎么用，要么孩子以某种方式将其转化为假装游戏或其他用途。他们并没有完全按照设计者预想的方式去使用。
And I think that's an amazing thing that kids can do. I mean, I've known parents, for example, who've decided that they never want their children to have a toy gun. And somehow, kids will figure out how to make something into a gun. If they want to play with guns, they're going to have a make-believe gun, right? I mean, it's just the creative end of childhood. Dr. Cudrowitz, you were quoted in a recent article talking about the fact that toy makers worry that kids are losing interest in toys at a younger age than they use. to? Is that actually happening? And if it is, why do you think so? So this is related to the concept of age compression. There's probably other terms related
我认为孩子们能做到这一点非常了不起。我的意思是，我认识一些家长，他们决定永远不让孩子玩玩具枪。但不知何故，孩子们总能想办法把东西变成枪。如果他们想玩枪，他们就会制造一把假想的枪，对吧？我的意思是，这就是童年的创造力。库德罗维茨博士，您在最近的一篇文章中被引用，谈到玩具制造商担心孩子们在比过去更小的年龄就对玩具失去了兴趣。这真的在发生吗？如果是，您认为为什么？这与“年龄压缩”的概念有关。可能还有其他相关的术语
to this. We talked to Doris about that, but it seems like kids are playing with the stuff that the older kids were playing with in the past. And this may be more of an artifact of technology advancing to the degree that things that we used to play with in the past were I don't want to say dumb, but they didn't have high tech inside because that was expensive. And in today's society, you can put LEDs in anything and it's relatively low cost. You could put motors in things and processors and there's computers in everything, you know, in my pocket right now. And it's not that much more expensive in today's society. And so a lot of the things that children are playing with today are not,
我们和多丽丝谈过这个，但看起来孩子们正在玩过去大孩子才玩的东西。这可能更多是科技进步带来的结果，即我们过去玩的东西——我不想说它们很笨，但它们内部没有高科技，因为那很昂贵。而在今天的社会，你可以在任何东西里装上LED灯，成本相对较低。你可以给东西装上电机和处理器，每样东西里都有电脑，你知道，我现在口袋里就有一台。在今天的社会，这并没有贵多少。所以孩子们今天玩的很多东西，
necessarily video games, but they're more like technology. And in the market space, some of those things kind of get lumped into consumer electronics and not necessarily in the toy aisle. And so, again, it kind of goes back to maybe marketing in some ways, but also you're not necessarily seeing kids play with the same toys as they were years ago. And there's a lot more screens and digital things in their hands. As a long-time observer of play and interviewing of adults' memories of their childhood pay, I definitely agree with Barry that the way play, the time and the experiences children have in play now has changed quite a bit.
不一定是电子游戏，但它们更像是科技产品。在市场上，其中一些东西被归类为消费电子产品，而不一定在玩具区。所以，这在某种程度上又回到了营销问题，但你也不一定能看到孩子们像几年前那样玩同样的玩具了。他们手中有了更多的屏幕和数字产品。作为一名长期的玩耍观察者，并采访过成年人对童年玩耍的记忆，我绝对同意巴里的观点，即玩耍的方式、孩子们现在玩耍的时间和体验已经发生了很大的变化。
When you think back to your own playtime, or certainly many other people who have either interviewed. They recall long periods of time where they pretty much could decide what they wanted to do with the time. And the kind of play materials they had were ones that they created, they made the toy talk, or they made the toy walk, or they did whatever it was with their own imagination. And now, so many of the toys, the toy does everything. There's really not much for the child to do. And so that toy is not going to be nearly as important in terms of children's development or their interest level, because if you're just, there's 10 buttons to push and
当你回想自己的玩耍时光，或者采访过的许多其他人时。他们回忆起很长一段时间里，他们几乎可以决定自己想怎么利用这段时间。他们拥有的玩耍材料是他们自己创造的，他们让玩具说话，或者让玩具走路，或者用他们自己的想象力做任何事情。而现在，太多的玩具，玩具本身就做了一切。孩子真的没什么可做的了。所以那个玩具在儿童发展或兴趣水平方面就不会那么重要了，因为如果你只是，有10个按钮要按，
you've pushed all 10 buttons, and then that's really the end of, what you can do with the toy, usually that what you see the child do is either put it away and not look at it anymore or pick it up and pretend it's something altogether different and use imagination and do something else with it. So I do think that that change and certainly that idea that experiences have gone down to lower levels is not just, related to toys, but it's pervasive across a lot of other things for children today. But I do think I've often thought the people designing the technology are the ones that are having the playful time because they're the ones that get to figure out what to do with it
你按完了所有10个按钮，那通常就是你能用这个玩具做的所有事情了。你看到孩子做的通常要么是把它收起来不再看它，要么是把它拿起来假装它是完全不同的东西，发挥想象力做点别的。所以我确实认为这种变化，当然还有那种体验水平下降的想法，不仅仅与玩具有关，而且在当今儿童的许多其他事物中都很普遍。但我确实经常认为，设计这些技术的人才是真正享受玩耍时光的人，因为他们是那些能弄清楚怎么玩它的人，
and so on. So it's the grownups who are coming up with these ideas. The kids aren't asking for the toys to be, yeah. So are you recommending that parents give their kids like dolls that don't do anything except sit there? They still make those. I know. One of the things that concerns me a great deal is if you remember back to your childhood, maybe all summer, you didn't have anything to do except just figure out what to play with yourself. Now children's lives are very structured, both after school and in summer. And so they don't necessarily have those long periods of time where they can really create their own play world. So that's a very, very different thing that we see now. So let me ask a kind of a developmental question. Maybe this is for Dr. Bergen,
等等。所以是成年人在想出这些点子。孩子们并没有要求玩具变成这样。那么，您是建议家长给孩子买那种除了坐在那儿什么都不做的玩偶吗？他们还在生产那种玩偶。我知道。让我非常担心的一点是，如果你回想自己的童年，也许整个夏天，你除了自己想办法玩什么之外，什么事都没有。现在孩子们的生活非常有条理，无论是课后还是暑假。所以他们不一定有那些可以真正创造自己玩耍世界的长段时间。所以这是我们现在看到的非常、非常不同的情况。那么让我问一个发展方面的问题。也许这是问伯根博士的，
although you're both welcome to answer it. But what happens to children who grow up without actual toys? Do they develop differently? And are they different as adults? That's a really interesting question. I really don't know of any research that's really looked at children who grow up without play because the research that, let's say, would be done in a country where there were very few toys show that children play anyway. They don't necessarily have to have toys to play. So it's more of a question, I guess, if you had children who had to go to work at age six or something like that. And I don't really know that's a very important issue. Probably should be studied. But I don't really know of the case that there are children who have any play experiences,
尽管你们两位都可以回答。但是，那些在没有实际玩具的情况下长大的孩子会怎样？他们的发展会有所不同吗？他们成年后会有所不同吗？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我真的不知道有任何研究真正关注过在没有玩具的情况下长大的孩子，因为研究表明，在玩具很少的国家，孩子们依然会玩耍。他们不一定非要有玩具才能玩。所以这更多是一个问题，我想，如果你有孩子在六岁时就不得不去工作之类的。我真的不知道这是一个非常重要的问题。可能应该被研究。但我真的不知道有孩子没有任何玩耍体验的案例，
but they may be very different kinds of play experiences. They may have play experiences where they use whatever is in their environment and create their own play as compared to the kind of play that Barry was mentioning where they have many, many toys, but a lot of toys have all these characteristics that just require you to push a button or something like that. So I think there's a wide range of play experiences, but at least in my experience, children, even if they have 10 or 15 minutes of their own time, are going to find something to play. Going back to the last thing that Dora said, on technology maybe restricting play, and that is true, that happens, but it can also be used for good.
但他们可能有非常不同的玩耍体验。他们可能有利用环境中的任何东西来创造自己玩耍的体验，相比之下，巴里提到的那种拥有很多很多玩具，但很多玩具都有那些只需要按一下按钮之类的特征的体验。所以我认为玩耍体验的范围很广，但至少在我的经验中，孩子们即使只有10或15分钟的个人时间，也会找到东西来玩。回到多拉说的最后一点，关于科技可能限制玩耍，这是真的，这种情况确实发生了，但它也可以被用于好的方面。
And designers can create open-ended play experiences for children taking advantage of technology. So, you know, they could create new types of musical instruments or things where children can program their own things to do whatever they want. What is the Spider-Man quote? You know, with great power comes great responsibility. you know, it's in the hands of the designer to create those good toys. I agree with that. I just think that if there's only one way to use a toy, that it's hard for children to use it for a long time period.
设计师可以利用科技为孩子们创造开放式的玩耍体验。所以，你知道，他们可以创造新型乐器，或者让孩子们可以编程来做他们想做的任何事情。蜘蛛侠的那句名言是什么？你知道，“能力越大，责任越大”。你知道，创造那些好玩具的责任在设计师手中。我同意这一点。我只是认为，如果一个玩具只有一种使用方式，那么孩子很难长时间使用它。
So as long as, you know, there are many different things to do with it, even if it's got a lot of technology enhancement, I think it can be a toy that has a lot of playability. So Dr. Carderowitz, one for you, do commercial toy designers think about developmental psychology while they're designing toys? I mean, do toy companies routinely have psychologists that they consult with, that they have them on staff? And are those toys different or better? Well, I think this is probably a question for Doris, because I think she was, she's consulted for those big companies. but I can say that, you know, not all toy companies are large and can afford consultation.
所以只要，你知道，有很多不同的玩法，即使它有很多科技增强，我认为它也可以是一个具有很高可玩性的玩具。那么库德罗维茨博士，问您一个问题，商业玩具设计师在设计玩具时会考虑发展心理学吗？我的意思是，玩具公司是否经常有他们咨询的心理学家，或者有专职的心理学家？这些玩具是否不同或更好？嗯，我想这可能要问多丽丝，因为我想她曾经，她为那些大公司做过咨询。但我可以说，你知道，并非所有的玩具公司都是大型的，能够负担得起咨询费用。
And so, you know, it's probably generally those big, the big players that could bring in consultants like Doris on these things. Yeah, I'll pick up on that because I did, and a lot of other developmental psychology people, did do a lot of work for Fisher Price. they had their headquarters in New York for a long long time and they would bring us there and we would look at the toys at the stage before they were in their final stage and we would evaluate them and describe what we thought might be good developmental aspects and what would work and what wouldn't and so on and that was really a very important thing and that's why
所以，你知道，通常可能只有那些大玩家才能请得起像多丽丝这样的顾问来处理这些事情。是的，我来接这个话题，因为我，还有许多其他发展心理学人士，确实为费雪（Fisher-Price）做了很多工作。他们长期在纽约设有总部，他们会把我们带到那里，我们在玩具最终定型前的阶段观察它们，我们会评估它们，描述我们认为可能好的发展方面，什么可行，什么不可行等等，那确实是一件非常重要的事情，这就是为什么
Fisher-Price toys were always so very playable and very good for development. Once Fisher-Price got taken over, I think, by another company, I don't think they still have those consultants that they did at that time. But there may be some other toy companies that do have consultants. But I originally thought that was really a good process because it was at the time of where there could still be some fine-tuning of the toy, but the basic toy was already designed. And I think that made the toys really more playable
费雪玩具总是那么具有可玩性，对发展非常有益。一旦费雪被另一家公司收购，我想，他们可能不再拥有当时那样的顾问了。但可能还有其他玩具公司有顾问。但我最初认为那确实是一个很好的过程，因为它处于还可以对玩具进行微调的阶段，但基本玩具已经设计好了。我认为这种来自心理学家的投入使玩具变得更加具有可玩性，
and more developmentally appropriate by having that input from psychologists. So Dr. Bergen, you studied play in China. Dr. Katowicz, you worked on toy design in the Netherlands. Do the types of toys that kids like to play with very much around the world, or are they pretty much universal? I guess I would say as far as China, I didn't see any big differences.
也更符合发展规律。那么伯根博士，您在中国研究过玩耍。库德罗维茨博士，您在荷兰从事过玩具设计。孩子们喜欢玩的玩具类型在世界各地差异很大吗，还是它们基本上是通用的？我想我会说，就中国而言，我没有看到任何大的差异。
When I was there, there wasn't a lot of, where I was, it was not a rich environment, and so a lot of the play was pretty basic. But, you know, things like balls and dolls and toy trucks and various things like that were pretty much the same there. They also played a lot of games outdoors, and outdoor play was very big at the time I was in China. I really don't know what it's like now. But that was quite a long time ago. What about in the Netherlands?
我在那里的时候，没有太多，我所在的地方，那不是一个富裕的环境，所以很多玩耍都是相当基础的。但是，你知道，像球、玩偶、玩具卡车和各种类似的东西在那里基本是一样的。他们也玩很多户外游戏，在我待在中国的时候，户外玩耍非常盛行。我真的不知道现在是什么样了。但那是很久以前的事了。荷兰那边呢？
It wasn't too different. I'm always looking for new stuff. And so being in a new environment, I felt inspired. And I felt like all the toys were cooler there because they're all, you know, different. But I was just on sabbatical, actually, a couple years ago there. And it was my first introduction to Montessori. and so we had our two-year-old in a Montessori daycare. And that style of play was really exciting.
差别不大。我一直在寻找新东西。所以身处一个新环境，我感到很受启发。我觉得那里的所有玩具都更酷，因为它们都是，你知道，不同的。但我几年前在那里休假。那是我第一次接触蒙特梭利教育。所以我们把两岁的孩子送进了蒙特梭利日托中心。那种玩耍风格真的很令人兴奋。
The toys are like real stuff. It's like, you know, prepping vegetables and cleaning and stuff. And it's turning these everyday activities, you know, into play in some ways. They have these kind of border eye, which are these kind of children farms. I guess, in the city. And you bring, you know, the family goes, and the kids take care of the animals, and they harvest vegetables, and they can go, and they take these little tiny kid-sized wheelbarrows and shovels, and they go into the pasture, and they pick up cow poop.
玩具就像真实的东西。就像，你知道，准备蔬菜、打扫卫生之类的。这在某种程度上把这些日常活动变成了玩耍。他们有那种“儿童农场”，我想，在城市里。你带，你知道，全家一起去，孩子们照顾动物，收获蔬菜，他们可以去，他们拿着这些小小的儿童尺寸的独轮车和铲子，走进牧场，捡起牛粪。
And they do that for like an hour. And it's like, and it's plate. This sounds like a con. This is how you make children do work. No, and my son is like, can we go back to the farm and do more of that, right? And it's getting out into nature, connecting with animals. You know, these are tools that aren't usually their size. And so there's some novelty about that, too.
他们一玩就是一个小时。而且就像，而且这是玩耍。这听起来像个骗局。这就是你让孩子干活的方式。不，我儿子说，我们能回农场多做点那个吗，对吧？这是走进大自然，与动物建立联系。你知道，这些工具通常不是他们那个尺寸的。所以这也有一种新奇感。
Yeah, and I think that European play researchers and have studied a lot of outdoor play because they're very much more focused on the natural environment and doing things outdoors in many of the countries in Europe, not so much here as they do there, but that's been a very strong emphasis, I think, in Europe altogether. I think, though, that what I've found is that children's types of play are very similar wherever you are, And it may be that they use a manufactured toy that is designed specifically for something,
是的，我认为欧洲的玩耍研究人员研究了很多户外玩耍，因为他们更关注自然环境，在欧洲的许多国家，户外活动比我们这里多得多，但我想，这在欧洲一直是一个非常强烈的重点。不过，我发现的是，无论你在哪里，儿童的玩耍类型都非常相似。可能他们使用的是专门为某种目的设计的制造玩具，
or if they're in an environment where there isn't a manufactured toy that fits whatever it is they want to do, they can invent something else to use. You can use a piece of wood to be a truck if you want to, if you don't have a real truck. You can use a rag and a ball to be a baby if you really don't have a real doll. So I don't think that necessarily the types of things children play are that different. I do think that there are many different materials they use in different places. But pretend play and game play and exploratory practice play, just doing over and over and expanding things.
或者如果他们身处的环境中没有适合他们想做的事情的制造玩具，他们可以发明其他东西来使用。如果你想要的话，你可以用一块木头当卡车，如果你没有真正的卡车。如果你真的没有真正的玩偶，你可以用一块抹布和一个球当婴儿。所以我认为孩子们玩的东西的类型不一定那么不同。我确实认为他们在不同地方使用的材料有很多不同。但假装游戏、游戏活动和探索性练习游戏，只是反复做和扩展事物。
Those are all very common types of play that you would see just really wherever you were in the world, I think. So I mentioned in the intro that Dr. Cuthrwood's one of your first toy designs was a pooping ketchup bottle. And Dr. Bergen, you've been quoted in a couple of recent articles about why kids are so interested in potty humor and toys that defecate. And since we're on the poop topic here, what is it about bathroom humor and potty-related toys that kids find so irresistible? Well, why do adults laugh at jokes that have those same kind of elements? The only difference is that young children don't have a lot of experiences. So bathroom stuff is one of the few, quote, shocking things that you're not supposed to talk about. So obviously, that's the one they focus on.
那些都是非常常见的玩耍类型，我想无论你在世界上的什么地方，你都会看到。所以我在开场白中提到，库德罗维茨博士，您的第一批玩具设计之一是一个会拉屎的番茄酱瓶。伯根博士，您在最近的几篇文章中被引用，谈到为什么孩子们对厕所幽默和排泄玩具如此感兴趣。既然我们在这里谈论大便话题，孩子们觉得浴室幽默和如厕相关的玩具如此不可抗拒的原因是什么？嗯，为什么成年人会对有同样元素的笑话发笑？唯一的区别是幼儿没有太多的经验。所以浴室里的东西是少数几个“令人震惊”的、你不应该谈论的事情之一。所以很明显，那是他们关注的焦点。
Their motivation, at least in my view, is absolutely no difference than the adult to tell some kind of a scatological joke or whatever. It's just that that's the material they have to act on and about being funny and being shocking. Scatological. Wow, I'm going to use that word in my book. Yeah, I don't know. Potty humor, they get reinforced, right? Whether it's good or bad, but if, you know, the child says something, they're going to get laughs, you know, it could be uncomfortable laughs or it could be actual laughs or it could be scolding, but they get feedback and they know it will consistently get feedback. And so we've had a very hard time getting our five-year-old to stop saying.
他们的动机，至少在我看来，与讲某种排泄笑话的成年人没有任何区别。只是那是他们可以用来表现“有趣”和“令人震惊”的素材。排泄的。哇，我要在我的书里用这个词。是的，我不知道。厕所幽默，他们得到了强化，对吧？无论是好是坏，但如果，你知道，孩子说了什么，他们会得到笑声，你知道，这可能是尴尬的笑声，也可能是真正的笑声，或者可能是责骂，但他们得到了反馈，他们知道这会持续得到反馈。所以我们很难让我们五岁的孩子停止说
poop all the time. And it's just like ignoring it eventually is the, yeah. Well, and I've done, you know, developmental study of children's humor. And you see that's a particular stage. And later, they're going to do other shocking things or tell you a joke that wouldn't be appropriate either. But it's just that with humor, a lot of humor is designed to have some sort of shocking quality. to it because that's what makes it funny. So you use whatever is available at your own experience level. And there's been some interesting study of, you know, the differences in men's and women's humor.
“大便”这个词。最终忽略它就是，是的。嗯，我做过，你知道，儿童幽默的发展研究。你会看到那是一个特定的阶段。后来，他们会做其他令人震惊的事情，或者给你讲一个同样不合适的笑话。但只是对于幽默来说，很多幽默被设计成具有某种令人震惊的特质，因为那正是让它变得有趣的原因。所以你使用你自身经验水平内可用的任何东西。并且有一些关于，你知道，男女幽默差异的有趣研究。
And if you look at it closely, it has a lot to do with what have been their life experiences. So it's just the same kind of thing. Potty humor is very funny to young children. because that's a very important thing in their life. If you recall, there's a lot of attention their adults have paid to how they manage that. So it's a good thing to make jokes about and to find funny. So shifting gears here, a few years ago, there were a number of news stories about major retailers, such as Target, getting rid of boys and girls' labels in their toy departments.
如果你仔细观察，它与他们的生活经历有很大关系。所以这只是同样的事情。厕所幽默对幼儿来说非常有趣，因为那是他们生活中非常重要的事情。如果你回想一下，成年人对他们如何管理那件事给予了极大的关注。所以拿它开玩笑并觉得有趣是一件好事。那么转换一下话题，几年前，有许多关于塔吉特（Target）等大型零售商取消玩具部门“男孩”和“女孩”标签的新闻报道。
I'm just wondering what role gender plays in kids' toy preferences and in how they play with toys. I mean, I think it's all fabricated to some degree by marketing. And when I was little, I just wanted to play with the easy bake oven. But I think it was only in pink or something. That's all I wanted, right? And then it was like, no, that's a girl toy because it's pink and it's cooking. I don't know. I thought that was weird.
我只是想知道性别在孩子的玩具偏好以及他们玩玩具的方式中扮演什么角色。我的意思是，我认为这在某种程度上完全是营销捏造的。当我小时候，我只想玩“Easy-Bake Oven”（简易烘焙烤箱）。但我认为它只有粉红色的还是什么的。那是我想要的全部，对吧？然后就像，不，那是女孩玩具，因为它是粉红色的，而且是烹饪。我不知道。我觉得那很奇怪。
Now it's not. You know, it's in different colors. And for us, you know, we just, we get our kids whatever they want to play with. And we're trying not to say that is, that's a gendered thing. Sorry, our son has, you know, this probably more clothes that are labeled as girls' clothes in prior times. He has a lot of dresses and skirts. And I think with art, what is the art class, I think that's the brand. It's just a lot of, it's all mixed up together.
现在不是了。你知道，它有不同的颜色。对我们来说，你知道，我们给孩子买任何他们想玩的东西。我们尽量不说那是性别化的东西。抱歉，我们的儿子有，你知道，这可能比以前有更多被贴上女孩衣服标签的衣服。他有很多裙子。我想对于“Art Class”这个品牌，我想那是那个品牌。它只是很多，全都混在一起了。
And there's no calling out this is for a boy or a girl. And I think a lot more parents feel that way now than they used to. But the toy companies and the toy stores and all of them are still egregious about that because they are always determined to label boys' toys and girls' toys. I would agree with Barry that the typical child will play with anything that they find interesting, and there are times when dressing up is great for everybody, and there's times when pushing cars around are great for everybody to be doing. And so children would not be making those boys.
没有说这是给男孩还是女孩的。我认为现在有更多的家长有这种感觉。但玩具公司、玩具店和所有这些机构在这一点上仍然非常过分，因为他们总是执着于给男孩玩具和女孩玩具贴标签。我同意巴里的观点，典型的孩子会玩任何他们觉得有趣的东西，有时候装扮对每个人来说都很棒，有时候推着车到处跑对每个人来说都很棒。所以如果成年人没有推波助澜，孩子们就不会做出那些男孩和女孩的区分。
and girl distinctions, if adults were not promoting that. And if you ask a lot of parents, unfortunately, even today, they would say, oh, I would only want to buy that for a boy or I don't want to buy that for a girl. But it's kind of working against that tide of advertisements and store directions to allow your child to have as wide a range of toys as they want to have as Barry's trying to do. And I do think it's worse now than it used to be. There was a one-time period in my professional career where there was a real attempt to take those labels off of the toys and then it gradually crept back on everything again. So I'm hoping if it's the case that there begin. You're
如果你问很多家长，遗憾的是，即使在今天，他们也会说，哦，我只想给男孩买那个，或者我不想给女孩买那个。但要让你的孩子拥有他们想要的尽可能广泛的玩具，就像巴里试图做的那样，这有点像是在逆着广告和商店导向的潮流而行。而且我确实认为现在比过去更糟了。在我职业生涯中有一个时期，确实有人试图去掉玩具上的那些标签，然后它又逐渐爬回了所有东西上。所以我希望如果情况是伯根博士所说的。你
beginning to get rid of those labels again, it would be great. But I haven't seen much evidence of that as yet. That sounds like it probably mirrors what's happening politically in a given country or in the world. So I'm sure that you both know adults who continue to be fascinated with toys. Do we ever really outgrow them? Do our toys just get bigger and more complicated and maybe more expensive? I think you never outgrow it, but the labels change. So instead of it being, I'm playing with this, it's something else. I have a hobby that I collect dolls, or I have a hobby that I fly automatic planes or whatever. So play is a basic human characteristic. It is going to be present hopefully for all of us all our life. And we should have times when we're playful and we're enjoying
开始再次去掉那些标签，那将是伟大的。但我还没有看到太多证据。这听起来可能反映了某个国家或世界上正在发生的政治情况。所以我相信你们两位都认识那些继续对玩具着迷的成年人。我们真的会摆脱它们吗？我们的玩具只是变得更大、更复杂，也许更贵了？我认为你永远不会摆脱它，但标签变了。所以不再是，我正在玩这个，而是别的东西。我有一个收集玩偶的爱好，或者我有一个驾驶自动飞机的爱好等等。所以玩耍是一种基本的人类特征。希望它会伴随我们一生。我们应该有玩耍的时间，享受
things that aren't getting graded or don't have to be paid for, whatever. But I think that we call them by different names. As an adult, you're in a play maybe, but you're not playing, but you're still pretending. You're taking a role. You're acting, so forth. So that's That's a playful type of activity adults would do. And that's true for a lot of other adult activities. But we don't call them play. We call them hobbies or we call them a whole wide range of things. So I don't know why the word play doesn't continue to get used as much as it should be
那些不需要被评分或不需要付费的东西，等等。但我认为我们用不同的名字称呼它们。作为一个成年人，你在戏里可能，但你不是在玩，但你仍然在假装。你在扮演一个角色。你在表演，等等。所以那是成年人会做的玩耍类型。这对许多其他成人活动也是如此。但我们不称它们为玩耍。我们称它们为爱好，或者我们称它们为各种各样的东西。所以我不知道为什么“玩耍”这个词没有像它应该的那样被继续使用，
because the playful quality of humans is one of our, in my view, best qualities. Yeah, I mean, some areas it stays. Like when we're playing video games still as adults or we're playing sports, for example. But in general, it's not like, hey, guys, you want to come over my house and play. Right. You don't call your friends as an adult and say that unless you're saying cards, maybe. Right. But yeah, the activities just get more challenging or they get more fine motor skill.
因为人类的玩耍特质，在我看来，是我们最好的特质之一。是的，我的意思是，有些领域它保留了下来。比如我们成年后仍然玩电子游戏，或者我们参加体育运动，例如。但总的来说，不是说，嘿，伙计们，你们想来我家玩吗？对。你不会作为成年人给你的朋友打电话说那样的话，除非你在打牌，也许。对。但是的，活动只是变得更具挑战性，或者它们变得更需要精细动作技能。
So it goes from, you just think about puzzles, right? You're starting with the four-piece puzzle as a little baby and then, or a toddler, and you get to like the 100-piece puzzle and then an adult, you're still doing puzzles, but they're a thousand-piece, right? And maybe they have like- And it's still fun. Yeah, and it's still fun, right? Or even skill-like-based, you know, it goes from like stacking, you know,
所以它从，你只想到拼图，对吧？你从婴儿时期开始玩四块拼图，然后，或者幼儿时期，你玩到100块拼图，然后成年后，你仍然在玩拼图，但它们是一千块的，对吧？也许它们有像——而且它仍然很有趣。是的，而且它仍然很有趣，对吧？或者甚至是基于技能的，你知道，它从像堆叠，你知道，
or the Nerf blasters to archery or something. It's like your motor skills get better. Your budget gets higher. You can put more time and money into these hobbies or recreation. And we just start to not associate it with that word because that word tends to mean for kids or trivial, right? But it's still play. It's just it's more fine-tuned. It's more advanced.
或者Nerf发射器到射箭之类的。就像你的运动技能变得更好了。你的预算更高了。你可以投入更多的时间和金钱在这些爱好或娱乐上。我们只是开始不再把它与那个词联系起来，因为那个词往往意味着给孩子玩的或琐碎的，对吧？但它仍然是玩耍。只是它更精细了。它更先进了。
Yeah. And we call it a hobby or we might just say, I want to do creative things, instead of saying play, I'm creating, and so forth. And I think that my one concern, I guess I'll have to say, going back to that earlier when we were talking about technology and how toys have now become so much more technologically designed, My view is the people who are having the playfulness are the people who are designing the stuff more than if it's a toy that you can only do one or two things with.
是的。我们称它为爱好，或者我们可能只是说，我想做有创造力的事情，而不是说玩耍，我正在创造，等等。而且我认为我唯一担心的，我不得不说，回到我们之前谈论科技以及玩具现在变得如此多地被技术化设计时，我的观点是，那些拥有玩耍乐趣的人是设计这些东西的人，而不是如果它是一个你只能做一两件事的玩具。
And so I would hope that as the toys get more sophisticated, that they continue to have many different ways they can be used. Because if a toy only has a few ways it can be used, it either is not going to be played with very much, or it's going to make children no longer having opportunities to play. If you're doing video games all the time or you're doing things that are very structured, you are not getting a chance to have wonderful ideas. There's been some really interesting research on adults who won McArthur Awards,
所以我希望随着玩具变得越来越复杂，它们继续拥有许多不同的使用方式。因为如果一个玩具只有几种使用方式，它要么不会被玩太多，要么会让孩子不再有机会玩耍。如果你一直在玩电子游戏或者做那些非常结构化的事情，你就没有机会产生美妙的想法。有一些关于赢得麦克阿瑟奖的成年人的非常有趣的研究，
and when they talked with a lot of them, they almost all said that what they most enjoyed when they were younger was what was called small world play, which is a kind of play that's allowed for elementary and older age kids. And it's like designing little structures where you make little towns or you make some kind of a small world, and then you still continue to interact in that small world, but it's appropriate for an older child
当他们与其中许多人交谈时，他们几乎都说他们年轻时最喜欢的是所谓的“小世界游戏”，这是一种允许小学生和更大年龄的孩子玩的玩耍。就像设计小结构，在那里你建造小城镇，或者你制作某种小世界，然后你继续在那个小世界里互动，但这适合大一点的孩子。
as compared to yourself taking on a pretend role or something like that. So the kind of play that older kids, I hope, still have, is where they can actually create the worlds and do things themselves and not just rely on the technology that lets them go into somebody else's wonderful idea of what is play, where they don't really get to do their own ideas of play. It sounds like you're also advocating for basically more unstructured time, right, for kids not to always be told now you've got to go play tennis because they may like tennis, but you're being forced to do it now as opposed to,
相比于你自己扮演一个假想角色之类的。所以我希望大一点的孩子仍然拥有的那种游戏，是他们能够真正创造世界并亲自动手去做，而不是仅仅依赖于那些让他们进入别人精彩游戏构想的技术，在那种技术下，他们并没有真正去实现自己的游戏构想。听起来你也在主张给孩子更多非结构化的时间，对吧？不要总是告诉他们现在必须去打网球，因为他们可能喜欢网球，但你现在强迫他们去打，而不是，
I think I'm going to go out in the street now and play ball with the kids. And Barry's done a lot about creativity. So you might want to talk a little bit about creativity's requirement for playfulness. Yeah, there's a number of studies that have shown you're more creative when you're playing or when you view an activity as play. And I think to just build off of the small world comet or the type of play, in today's world, a lot of adults and kids are building those imaginary worlds, but it's in the computer. And it's in Minecraft and Fortnite.
我想我现在要到街上去和孩子们一起玩球。巴里在创造力方面做了很多研究。所以你可能想谈谈创造力对游戏性的要求。是的，有很多研究表明，当你玩耍或将一项活动视为游戏时，你会更有创造力。我想在小世界评论或游戏类型的基础上补充一点，在当今世界，许多成年人和孩子都在构建那些想象中的世界，但那是在电脑里。是在《我的世界》和《堡垒之夜》里。
And it is creative. You're building things. You're making up your own stuff. But it's also on a screen. So I don't know, there's pros and cons there for sure. Yeah, I mean, there's something tactile if you, for example, make dollhouses or you've got a train set and you've created a whole layout of towns and so forth. It's very different from the experience of doing it just on a screen. So as we're moving into the holiday season, I think I opened with this and people are out buying toys,
而且这确实很有创造力。你在建造东西。你在编造自己的东西。但它也确实是在屏幕上。所以我不知道，这肯定有利有弊。是的，我的意思是，如果你制作玩偶屋，或者你有一套火车模型，并且你创建了整个城镇布局等等，这有一种触感。这与仅仅在屏幕上操作的体验非常不同。所以随着我们进入节日季，我想我开头就提到了这一点，人们都在外面买玩具，
Do you have any guidance suggestions for parents who are looking for gifts for their kids, toys that, whether they're classics or there's something, I mean, I'm not asking you to endorse a particular brand or a product, but sort of the concept of what would you recommend parents be looking for as they're trying to get their kids holiday presents? Wow. Okay. I get this a lot. And then I freeze. board game-wise, going to my research on creativity, I have a lot of favorites that I think build creative skills. My favorite game is actually called code names, and it's a game about divergent thinking and convergent thinking, and it's a word game. But it's now branched out into different properties, so there's a Disney version and a Marvel version and a Harry Potter version. And so you're likely to find one that resonates with your child. But I really, do like that game as far as the creative skills that it builds. I'm also partial to anything
对于那些正在为孩子寻找礼物、寻找玩具的父母，无论是经典款还是其他什么，你有什么建议吗？我的意思是，我不是让你为某个特定品牌或产品背书，而是从概念上讲，你建议父母在为孩子挑选节日礼物时应该寻找什么？哇。好的。我经常被问到这个问题。然后我就卡住了。就棋盘游戏而言，根据我对创造力的研究，我有很多最喜欢的游戏，我认为它们能培养创造性技能。我最喜欢的游戏其实叫《代号行动》，它是一个关于发散性思维和收敛性思维的游戏，是一个文字游戏。但它现在已经衍生出不同的版本，有迪士尼版、漫威版和哈利波特版。所以你很可能会找到一个能引起孩子共鸣的版本。但我确实非常喜欢那个游戏，因为它能培养创造性技能。我也偏爱任何
related to cooking and food. And I don't necessarily think it needs to be a toy version of a thing. So I'm not necessarily advocating for the easy bake oven. I'm advocating for maybe the kids' knife set that are actually knives. And it's the safer knife. but they're still knives, right? And like the kid peeler, vegetable peeler. And if there's any other fun products that children can play with you in the kitchen, for example, like a pasta maker, right? The hand crank pasta maker, at least once a month, the children view that as a toy. And we're making food together. And it's not that expensive of a kitchen tool. So just I guess think beyond the toy aisle is my recommendation.
与烹饪和食物相关的玩具。我不一定认为它必须是玩具版本的物品。所以我并不一定是在提倡易烘焙烤箱。我提倡的是也许给孩子一套真正的刀具。那是更安全的刀，但它们仍然是刀，对吧？还有像儿童削皮器，蔬菜削皮器。如果还有其他孩子们可以和你一起在厨房玩的有趣产品，例如，像面条机，对吧？手摇面条机，孩子们至少每月一次会把它当作玩具。我们在一起做食物。而且那不是什么昂贵的厨房工具。所以我建议大家跳出玩具区去思考。
Okay, my suggestion would be sure to have some games that everyone in the family can play. If you think back to your childhood, you can remember some of the best times when your whole family gathered together and played some kind of game. It might not have been a very intellectual game, but it was something that you could do together. And one of the things you learn is how to be a little better sport, if you're not always the one who's coming out, winning the game. But I think that that idea of engaging with your family in play is a very important one. The other suggestion I would have is that the more open-ended toys you can provide the better in terms of play value.
好的，我的建议是确保准备一些全家人都能玩的游戏。如果你回想自己的童年，你会记得全家人聚在一起玩某种游戏时的一些最美好的时光。那可能不是一个非常益智的游戏，但它是你们可以一起做的事情。你学到的其中一件事就是如何做一个更好的输家，如果你不是总是那个赢得游戏的人。但我认为那种与家人一起参与游戏的想法非常重要。我给出的另一个建议是，你提供的开放式玩具越多越好，就游戏价值而言。
that can be used in a number of different ways. Maybe they start out a certain way, but then you can kind of transform them into other things. And also, the idea that they don't have to be the most popular kind of name toy brand or whatever, but very simple things. Balls, for example, are still extremely popular toys. and just having a few different sizes of the balls and playing with them. But you do need to have either other children to play with or family members to do it.
可以以多种不同的方式使用。也许它们开始时是某种样子，但随后你可以将它们转化为其他东西。此外，它们不必是最受欢迎的品牌玩具之类的，简单的东西也可以。例如，球仍然是非常受欢迎的玩具。只要有几种不同大小的球并和它们一起玩。但你需要有其他孩子一起玩，或者有家庭成员参与。
And in a lot of my early research, I found kids used to play outside with a lot of other kids. And that seems to have been less common now. And so if they're not playing with other kids outside, then the family needs. needs to play with them or they have to play more with other kids at school or somewhere where they can learn some of the give and take. And as Paget would say, enhance their moral development. Well, thank you both. This has been really interesting. And I hope that we provided some good advice and guidance to parents and other caregivers of children who are looking for toys, particularly around this time of year, but all the time, because toys are, there's no season, right? Toys are,
在我早期的很多研究中，我发现孩子们过去常和很多其他孩子在外面玩。现在这种情况似乎不那么常见了。所以如果他们不在外面和其他孩子玩，那么家人就需要和他们一起玩，或者他们必须在学校或其他地方更多地和其他孩子玩，在那里他们可以学习一些礼尚往来。正如皮亚杰所说，增强他们的道德发展。好吧，谢谢你们两位。这非常有趣。我希望我们为那些正在寻找玩具的父母和其他儿童看护人提供了一些好的建议和指导，特别是在每年的这个时候，但其实一直都是这样，因为玩具，没有季节之分，对吧？玩具是，
for all time. So thank you both. Thanks. Enjoyably be here. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyant Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
永恒的。所以谢谢你们两位。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condyant。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。